[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: So one of the new
emerging kind of information
technology revolutions
that we're seeing nowadays
is this idea of
augmented reality.
This notion of taking the
world of everyday perception,
and tweaking it
and augmenting it,
and impregnating perception
with mindedness, with agency,
with aesthetics.
And so how do we do that?
Well, it essentially means that
the information technologies,
the instruments that
we're using today
to manipulate and
transform the world,
are now allowing us to overlay
digital information on top
of the physical world.
They have apps
already, that looking
through the camera in the app,
you can place virtual elements
into real environments.
So it's this notion that
you're mapping the real world
and overlaying agency
information, gamification,
mind, into it.
So what does that mean?
It means that more
and more of the world
starts to feel re-enchanted.
More and more of the
world can be turned
into gamified experiences.
There's more cognitive
activity occurring
in the interface
between self and world
until self and world become one.
Now I think that that's
where we're heading.
And certainly the idea
of augmenting reality
is part of what it
means to be human.
From the moment that we
started to create architecture,
to put objects in the world,
to make art, to carve tools,
we've been augmenting reality.
So for the digital revolution
to finally catch up to
that is a perfectly
natural emergence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]